كنت اعيش في كييف وحين بدات الحرب قررت ان
اتي الى بيت خالتي في هذه القريه ظننت انه
سيكون امنا لكن الحرب في كل مكان اصاب
القصف المنزل وشوه وجهي انقلبت حياتي منذ
تلك اللحظه
[موسيقى]
اول صفاره انذار سمعتها كانت نهايه اليوم
الاول لاننا كنا في القبو الذي لم يكن
صالحا للحياه لم استطع النوم في الليله
الاولى لذا قررت اللجوء الى المترو
ككثيرين كان اشبه بالجنه مقارنه بما يحدث
في الخارج والناس في الداخل انشا مجتمعا
متكاملا ومتكافلا بشكل رائع
في صباح اليوم التالي للحرب وبعدما
استنفرنا الاهاليا لاخراجهم من البلده
بدانا نرصده وصول المدرعات الروسيه باتجاه
مناطقنا واستطاعوا بالفعل احتلال مركز
الشرطه وقلب المدينه واحراقه لكننا بعد
شهر تمكنا من استعادتها وغانمنا كثيرا من
معداتهم
منذ اللحظات الاولى بدات باسعاف الجرحى
العسكريين والمدنيين في مستشفى ماريوبول
نتيجه القصف العنيف الذي استهدفها كنت
انهار احيانا من هول ما اراه لكنني كنت
مضطره للاستمرار الى ان تقدمت القوات
الروسيه واعتقلتني وانا في طريقي الى
زابولوجيا ولم استطع الخروج الا بصفقه
تبادل اذكر ان هذا الفيديو كان الاخير لي
قبل اعتقاله
كان منزل خالتي هنا لكنه انتهى تماما اذكر
اننا كنا نتناول الفطور عندما اصابتنا
القذيفه في اليوم السادس للحرب واظننت ان
كل شيء انتهى قضيت العام كله عالج جروحي
وها نحن نعود اقوياء مثل بلدي واعيننا على
النصر
كان هذا مكتبي كنت اعمل هنا كل يوم احترق
كل شيء لكننا استعدنا المقر وسنبنيه
ونحميه مجددا كما نفعل مع مدينتنا وبلدنا
استعدت حريتي والله فقط منحني القوه لاننا
اصحاب حق وسنواصل نضال من اجل قضيتنا
بعد كل ما مضى اثبتنا كاوكرانيين اننا
نقاوم ولا نستسلم نريد ان نواصل ونجتهد من
اجل حمايه بلدنا واستعاده حياتنا